Selena Gomez on the weekend continue  globe-trotting it's amazing the pair was  snapped shopping in Buenos Aires on  Tuesday and check out how smitten Selena  looks with her hands on her man's  shoulder keep my hands to myself Selena  kept a cute in a spaghetti strapped  black and gray pinstripe dress she  paired the look with sunglasses and  casual white sneakers the weekend also  looked fashionable and his trainers  paired with a camouflage bomber jacket  over black pants and a black tee the duo  have been traveling a ton together just  days ago Selena was in Brazil with a  singer at his concert she captured this  moment to him Mom stage yeah it was so  much fun  [Music]